So now as you might have guessed I've graphed the lines y equals x plus 10 over
the quantity x plus 2 times the quantity x minus 2, and of course our x axis.
What are we interested in finding now? Well because we have a less than 0 here
we want to see where the pink curve lies below the purple curve or below the X
axis. This region down here, this sort of upside down u definitely does. And as
you would expect, the x values here lie between negative 2 and 2, although this
curve will never actually have points with either of these two x values. We'll
talk about that more in a few lessons. Get excited, it's pretty cool stuff. For
the other part of our solution Where x lies between negative infinity and
negative ten. We once again, have a bit of a hard time telling that the curve
drops below the x axis here. But of course, you could plug in values for x that
are less than negative ten, and test this out yourself. I think this is pretty
cool though. You can use multiple graphs to demonstrate the same solution sets.
And we can see how 2 inequalities look completely different, or at least pretty
different to me, yield the exact same solutions.